ces militants de la cgtm soem sont en
grève depuis jeudi
déjà sept jours sans salaire et le
mouvement n'est pas près de s'arrêter
ce matin le discours d'edouard philippe
c'est d'abord voulu rassurant pour les
smicards évoquant une retraite garantie
de 1000 euros mais pour les syndicats
ses contours restent flous alors que
leur revendication principale le
maintien des régimes spéciaux est
officiellement en terme
aujourd'hui nous sommes un outil puisque
c'est la mort des régimes spéciaux nous
allons intensifier le mouvement est
l'exemple c'est un bon mouvement le
grand martin pour vous aucun signe qui
se voudrait positif dans ses annonces
bénédicte ou ccc diviser pour mieux
régner comment quelqu'un qui entre et
qu'il n'y a pas 75 rappaz bénéficie le
mans j'avais mauvais déficit c'est
seulement pour affaiblir le mouvement au
delà tout section est entré en 1975 ne
voulez plus vous est pas possible et que
nous devons prendre
non c'était pour casser le mouvement ils
ne sont pas d'accord on va continuer le
combat autres syndiqués en grève
illimitée depuis le 5 décembre et fo qui
bloquaient ce matin les accès de pôle
emploi et la banque postale à kerlys
militants du public ou du privé se
prépare à nouveau à battre le pavé le 17
ou non il ya eu un saupoudrage pour
faire plaisir à tout le monde essayait
de faire tomber la pression nous ne
sommes pas satisfaits
nous ne voulons pas de ce régime
universel par points de nous c'est le
régime par répartition on peut s'asseoir
autour d'une table négocié pour
l'améliorer pour la perfectionner oui
mais ça non et puis c'est quoi ce régime
pour les 2004 né en 2004 bien avant 1975
nés après 1975 ça c'est pas un régime
universel dans l'enseignement
pas de grève illimitée les préavis et en
a déposé 48 heures à l'avancé mais ils
le seront pour mardi prochain le calcul
des futures retraites inquiète encore
plus depuis le discours du premier
ministre
pour enseigner il faut faire des études
et qui des fois des études qui sont
longues parce qu'il faut déjà avoir un
master plus passer un concours donc
naturellement ce sont des personnels qui
entre ta dans le métier véritablement
donc plus on rentre tard dans le métier
plus ce sera difficile vis-à-vis des
retraites qui nous seront proposés donc
les choses sont claires on sera
naturellement défavorisés même si il y à
quelques petits aménagements qui sont
faits par l'état
il ne nous satisfont pas parce que
l'ensemble de la profession n'aura pas
droit à ces améliorations de leur
salaire pour pouvoir avoir une retraite
décente
tous les syndicats mobilisés hier seront
ils à nouveau dans la rue mardi prochain
et les rangs seront ils aussi fourni
l'absence de réformes pour les plus de
45 ans est en effet de nature à
affaiblir le mouvement